This World Cup champion received the
worst possible news after helping Spain
win it all Olga Carmona learned that her
father died after scoring the only goal
in Spain's World Cup victory she said it
was the best and worst day of her life
Carmona was named the final's most
valuable player and when she was
speaking to reporters after the game
ended she didn't indicate that she had
heard the devastating news yet Carmona's
family said that they made the decision
to wait to tell Olga until after the
game had ended that her father had died
it was reported that Carmona's father
was ill and had died while her mother
and other relatives were traveling to
Australia to watch her play in the final
later on X formerly known as Twitter
Carmona addressed her dad's death saying
how without knowing it she had her star
before the game started she said she
knew her dad gave her the strength to
achieve something unique and that he was
watching over her and he was proud of
her the Spanish soccer Federation wrote
on XA we love you Olga you are part of
the history of Spanish soccer